two one
everybody it is a treat I am talking to
a legend in this field this is Fraser
Kane his inaugural appearance on my
channel although yeah he's hosted me so
many times it's I I really feel guilty
first I mean I I I'm filled with guilt
all the time but but more so today thank
you for coming well that's good I mean
well I was pretty implicit about it last
time I'm like this is the last time I
interview you until you interview me and
then the then we're square and we can
continue on with this natural cycle that
we have together we had this uh calendly
battle where we set each other exactly I
said yeah keep a zoom invite no I say
yeah tell me when your calendars open
yeah the ultimate Flex is uh yeah I will
have my assistant use her flip phone or
his flip phone
set up an interview yeah oh you don't
have an assistant oh I'm so sorry oh the
universe today Empire is is uh being
stronger every day anyway Fraser this is
such a treat I want to get into so many
things with you I want to talk about
your yeah story I want to talk about
what excites you the most about our
universe I want to talk about your
phenomenal career and your writing uh
which inspires me and millions around
the world uh
you're so prolific it kind of uh you
know it puts Hemingway to shame and I
really want to use this to encourage you
to you know to turn your interviews and
everything that you do into a book
that's uh not many years uh in the past
but a new book and then I can have you
back on to do right segment that I call
judging books by their covers well hold
up so that is that it that's the real
like I can't come back on until I've
written another book that's your that's
your job I have to pass through yeah no
but seriously you do so much cool stuff
and and like partially you know I've
been looking forward to this for weeks
since I was on your show and that
episode I think it was your most popular
episode that whole day uh it was
incredible it got 10 000 views within
the first three months it's just that
yeah yeah definitely one of the more
successful interviews that I've done was
the conversation with you so uh yeah
yeah I was I was joking I was saying it
was the most popular video of your video
that particular day only uh you've
you've had uh so many incredible
interviews it was one of the most
successful interviews that I've done oh
well I I appreciate that yeah uh but
after the interview after we turned off
the mics we did a BTS you know kind of
thing where we were talking and you gave
me some life advice and I want to turn
to that later about where you see things
but but I want to get to know you and
have my my you know my audience is only
the square root of your audience but
they're the best in the universe of
course uh but I wanna I wanna start with
your origin story what got you into
astronomy what brought you to where you
are today up there in the great white
North there's going to be white North
hopefully
yeah so I mean I've always been into
astronomy as long as I can remember like
I was I I had a copy of our universe the
time like book I don't know if you
remember this yeah that I would just re
would go and watch meteor showers with
my parents I would watch science fiction
Star Trek I went through my dad's
science fiction books on his shelves
when I was old enough to to start taking
on novels I uh I watched the first space
shuttle launch in 1981
I bought my own telescope when I was
like 13 years old and the nerdiest thing
is that when I was in high school I was
I took the journalism program was like a
three-year program while I was in high
school and I did a column on
astronomy every month
for the years that I was in in high
school what you could see in the night
sky new discoveries in space and
astronomy it was it was hilarious and
then for some weird reason I didn't
continue on in that vein like you did
yeah I went I decided it would be a lot
more practical for me to go and take
engineering and then I shifted over to
computer science and then was in sort of
the computer field for many years and
but I was always interested in space and
astronomy and I was at this point where
I realized that my knowledge was sort of
stuck at a
six-year-old reading our universe and I
wanted to progress in in what I
understood about the current state of
space and astronomy I sort of had I had
the case for Mars in one hand written by
Bob zuberin and I had pale blue dot by
Carl Sagan and I read both those books I
got really inspired and I decided Well
I'm just going to start a website on the
side where I explain Concepts in space
and astronomy and
and by doing so I will learn and I just
did it as a as a side gig while I was
doing my main job and within about a
year I was like okay this is all I want
to do with the rest of my life like
whatever it's going to take I need to
stop
helping Banks make websites and I need
to start
being a space journalist and that was
1999 so I'm closing it on 24 years now
of of doing this
so the dark webs loss is astronomy yeah
yeah exactly yeah yeah
things you know whenever I think about
you uh
uh that you have exceptional taste and
I'm not just saying this you know
because you've had me on so many times
but but you actually have like a very
highly curated uh list of topics
um the way that you do your live streams
your q and A's and I wanted to ask you
first how do you know when something is
hype and something is uh legitimate how
do you filter that out what's the cane
method tell me please
well I mean it's funny is people like
you actually I have a council of experts
because like you know my background is
in computer science so I can help figure
out if I think an AI technology is going
to be nonsense or if someone is truly
proved that P equals not equal to NP but
but my
when I started I very much came to it
from a science fiction
enthusiasm state
wormholes white holes black you know
faster than warp speed whatever Star
Trek told me was true and I was really
lucky to have
a bunch of of astrophysicists that I got
a chance to talk with Dr Pamela gay was
a good example you know we did astronomy
cast and if you listen if you go back to
the early episodes I am just the why are
the real laws of physics that we have to
obey
and and then you know I was friends with
Phil plate work debunking stuff and and
then
uh you know I've had a chance to do a
lot of correspondence with Ethan Siegel
starts with a bang Dr Paul Sutter uh
Brian koberline who who writes with us
at Universe today and you just you get
your wrist slapped enough times
that you start to able to
strike that balance between
a genuine enthusiasm for interesting
things that are happening in space and
astronomy and a
Reckless
optimism for things that aren't really
science and
and I think the more you like I think
there's this cycle that people go in
where they first start out and they're
like I want to talk about Dyson spheres
you know and you're like okay sure yeah
we can talk about because that's what
you're into by all means but then after
a while you know they've checked their
watch and it's been a week later and
there's no Dyson spheres have shown up
they'll be like okay well then let's
talk about this Dart Mission thing and
now we're cooking now we've got some
interesting space news that is unfolding
and changing and there's new discoveries
being made
and and that's what I get really excited
about now is just like this perfect
balance between
what are we doing now and what's coming
up next what are the big Mysteries that
we have and where might we find those
answers in a way that's practical that
we might get somewhere within our lives
um talk to me about like how you
distinguish between the ultimately
popular I find this this phenomenon I
think it's called audience capture where
you have just you know kind of a topic
that you know is going to be garnering
you a lot of views and and yet
um it may not be along the lines of
something that you find as legitimate as
some of your other topics I mean you
mentioned Dyson spheres I can't resist
Freeman Dyson was the first guest on the
into the impossible podcast
um and uh and and of course he had his
he had his a kind of you know more far
out ideas and and More close yes uh yeah
you know lately in the Zeitgeist as they
say uh has been percolating this notion
that you know we are routinely being
visited by alien
um artifacts crafts and and I've I've
had on you know some of the big names in
the uh in the skeptic field you know
from Mick West uh Michael Shermer but
I've also had on a lot of you know
people that are proponents of it and and
really believe that we are being visited
by physics of the 29th century or
something like how do you know
um how to strike the balance because you
you also will have legitimate scientists
that present fact-based
um research I've had on more maybe
um let me ask you would you have on uh
uh you know my my past guest Tom Delong
I mean he was on the show uh I got a lot
of flack for that it actually is my most
popular I don't think it would yeah yeah
I'm sure it was popular but I probably
wouldn't no and people want to have a
plan too and I'm like I got as much but
I I before I ask you if you know how you
would react to that
um I just want to say that um I did get
him to actually answer some factual
questions that even Joe Rogan never
asked him like what is the provenance of
the alien artifacts that you're having
he actually admitted for the first time
I think that he can't prove a linear
chain of command from start to finish
anyway how do you know how to have that
balance um aliens are super popular
nowadays there is a UAP study being
undertaken by the president of the
Simons Foundation my My ultimate boss
David spurgle along with my my colleague
Shelly Wright here at UC San Diego how
do you know when to uh you know when to
lean into what your audience wants and
what you personally may or may not be
interested
so I am not super interested in
in trying to do stuff that the audience
wants
um I'm
everything I do is my curiosity
like if I'm not curious about this if
this is what I'm obsessing about right
now it just doesn't happen so so I it's
really simple it's just like whatever
I'm curious about whatever ideas I'm
ruminating on right now are what I will
I will book interviews with people I
will uh choose those topics for the news
segments like it like it's every part
like it's what we're covering on
Universe today it's who I'm interviewing
it's the kinds of questions I'm
gravitating towards answering it's just
what I'm I'm following my curiosity and
it doesn't it hasn't steered me wrong so
far and
and that the conversation that you have
with the viewers and I'm sure you have
the same one that they're in the chat
and they're asking for follow-up
questions you will eventually Reach the
the place of curiosity again like you
might
know the answers to the simple questions
about
um
the
like signals that are in the The Cosmic
microwave background radiation
Etc but you can have a conversation with
someone is that they just kept asking
you questions you would get to a place
where you're like I don't know I'm
curious again even something that you
know a field that you know quite well if
a person can can dig and be curious
after a while it's kind of infectious so
so I don't really
it's it's driven by my curiosity not
driven by me trying to optimize what
other people what I think other people
want to hear
um and I think that's important as it
sort of back to your your idea about
you know skepticism like like this idea
of are we alone in the universe is a
scientific question and anyone who tells
you that it isn't is ridiculous it is
absolutely a scientific question right
we're here we're on Earth life's
everywhere it's a big universe where is
all the life how could we search for
life
and and I find and I spend a ton of time
investigating that question
with the kinds of people that I talk to
et cetera but I but when a person
has anecdotal evidence
for something that they think they've
seen I don't find that compelling and so
you have to just kind of strike that
balance of like what is the kind of
evidence what are the kind of questions
what would it take to convince you like
like are there artifacts of alien
civilizations here in the the solar
system that's a really good question and
it's a really like if there was one way
that aliens would would travel from star
system to star system they would send
self-replicating robot probes that would
be pumping out more robot probes that
would be in a place where there's a lot
of minerals let's look in the asteroid
belt that's
a really compelling idea to me yeah
yeah
not
yeah not that they're flying through the
atmosphere and only a few people have
seen them and so on so I think it's they
weren't lurking on on the whatever the
asteroid that Dart smashed into because
that that would be a kind of rude
welcome to the solar system welcome to
the solar system yeah we we we caught
you smash yeah yeah so I think
um you always have to strike this
balance and as you learn more you
realize where you want to sit on that on
that conversation and my curiosity just
following my curiosity has never failed
me yeah yeah that I know of let's say
this taste that's that's kind of
remarkable and I also think you have uh
not to you know turn this into a mutual
admiration Society but or a
unidirectional admiration stuff but but
the fact is you have a very large
audience and I think there's more sort
of Gravitas that you know like when I
was small like when I had Tom Delong on
or when I
um you know had on some more speculative
game names 20 000 subscribers and I I
treasure each I fought hard for each and
every one but you have yeah a thousand
plus they you know plus the universe
today audience which is huge plus you're
huge following on Twitter and social
um there is an extra level I mean do you
uh you have this you know kind of
counsel of people that you talk to but
uh how does that weigh upon you because
you can actually be influential in a way
that a smaller Channel may not be able
to be
I think that's a ridiculous thing to say
to me
um and terrifying maker so if you so if
you think that I somehow have some kind
of although it does happen from time to
time like I'll reach out to someone I'm
like you know dear Dr so and so my name
is Fraser Kane I'm the publisher of
universe today and they'd be like I know
who you are Fraser yes I'd like to do an
interview and then I'll talk to them I'm
like yeah you know I was your work was
really influential to me while I was
getting my PhD and I'm just like
so I'm not worthy
um so I I mean like what can I do right
like like I'm a journalist I'm not a
scientist right and I'm I try to be
really clear about that that that when
I'm explaining Concepts in space and
astronomy I am just a fancy
word monkey who's able to repeat the
kinds of discoveries that people like
you make
right you're the one who set up a
telescope at the South Pole and tried to
find out the polarity of the cosmic
microwave background radiation not me
and so
um it's my job
to help you and people like you to be
able to explain the work that you're
doing in a way that it gets a fair shake
from people out there
beyond that you know I'm not a scientist
so I don't have any of that
responsibility
but there's a journalistic kind of
overlay that that is unique I look at
like what's the what's my
um unfair advantage to whatever extent I
have well I'm an actual scientist who's
a professor's tenured and gives you
something yeah and I'm doing experiments
I'm working with cool students and
scientists all literally on every
continent on Earth uh and
um but you know that's kind of like my
unique thing you're one of the few you
know in the science podcast I mean I've
talked with Arvin and papa Sabina and
I've talked with Dr Becky
um and they all have their unfair
advantages but I I've always thought
yours is that I mean you have this
journalistic it's not like a cakewalk to
go on the podcast I mean you're you're
not gonna ask like do you deny the
allegations against you made by those 14
Sherpas yeah I mean you're not gonna do
that but you have a journalistic
um uh kind of mentality which I think is
a fair Advantage I mean I don't wanna
again I don't wanna yeah I mean I think
like my job and you know I don't have to
put people's feet to the fire very often
and but when I have to I will and and
I'm not trying to be mean about it and
I'm not trying to be a gotcha and I'm
not trying to generate controversy but
when I ask a person a question and they
don't answer the question it's really
obvious to me that they did they just
didn't answer the question and I get to
ask again and again and and like like am
I you know I could say like am I am I
doing this did you not catch the
question that I just asked you because
the answer you gave me was was
insufficient let me try again and so you
know you don't want to have to
pull out the journalism card because you
want it to be a conversation and most of
the time it's just educational I don't
know anything about what it is that
they're talking about or I know very
little and but if I have to
then I will yeah and and I suffer no
consequences from that
through because I don't have any
professional
interaction with them right it's not
like I'm it's not like I'm they're gonna
be approving my grant right I'm
independent Universe today is completely
100 independent we have no allegiance to
anybody and so we can kind of float free
like a you know like a leaf in the wind
and uh we are floating through our solar
system but I do want to make yeah
exactly yeah you join uh patreon as I am
I am a Moon member I think uh for many
many trillions of of microseconds and uh
but I do want to uh encourage people to
support Fraser the best way you can do
that as follows content and then
uh as well we're talking with Fraser
Kane the proprietor of universe today so
many other things uh puts out so much
content uh but I noticed one one thing
that you do and I I don't know anything
about you
um you know religiously or otherwise but
um it seems to me you take a Sabbath you
take a you take a break every year from
from the crime that is it and you were
very concrete you're like I'd like to
have you on you know I invited myself on
again you know last year and you're
gracious we say like I take a sabbatical
basically for the whole month of August
or most of August
um July and August July and August okay
so are you out there just like fly
fishing on the on the camera no I wish
River in Vancouver what are you doing
what does it mean to you to take that
break and what you how would you advise
other stem individuals most of my
podcasts or yeah yeah 20 to 860 or
whatever older men uh but they're in the
stem field advise them why is that so
important I agree with you 100 percent
yeah like the
our lives are spent doing a lot of
administration a lot of detail work like
a lot of just paddling to to keep your
head above water but the most important
impacts that we can make are the time
that's spent in quiet contemplation the
time spent where there are no
um
demands on your time and you can think
and your ideas and thoughts can fully
expand within the the the space that is
that is needed and so on the one hand
like while I'm walking in the forest or
while I'm cutting down a tree with a
chainsaw
um my mind is expanding and I am
thinking very deeply about the work that
I'm doing and and and reflecting on what
it is that I do and I and I wouldn't
have that time if I wouldn't have the
chance to have those thoughts if I was
just constantly just grinding all the
time so yeah so we've been we've been
doing this I've done this for 15 years
um I I let everybody know there's no
meetings there's no live streams there's
no podcasts there's no nothing
for July and August we stop astronomy
cast we stopped the weekly space hangout
we stopped my open space it all just
stops at the you know July 30th and then
we pick it all back up again September
1st
and it's two months that I get a chance
to to travel to get away from having to
be tied to a high-speed internet
connection I mean I'm sure you know what
it's like like you can never be like
you're in a hotel and you're like oh I
got a live stream I gotta figure this
out you know
like that's not fun so yeah it's
important to do that so I mean I think
you
I mean that's why I think the those
sabbaticals exist is that
you've got to
or you'd just be spent spinning your
wheels until you die yeah you'll burn
out and uh and then you know you have to
put your oxygen mask on first as they
say and I think that's a huge part of it
um it's hard for you know people like me
who's you know got a you know multiple
careers and young kids and everything uh
because but but I find it do I do find
it so refreshing and actually I tell my
students that I say you um you may not
work seven days a week but I am almost
like you must work six days a week in
other words like the fact that you earn
a sabbatical is something that to be
earned and of course they'd get time off
and they get travel and so on but I find
that it's ultimately selfish for me to
do that because they come back energize
refresh with new ideas that serves to
inspire me
um and you know they have to try these
hacks of like oh delete you know get a
get up turn all your icons black on your
phone and why it it never works um you
know no no technology is great no yeah
there was a I went on a like I've put at
one job and I went on this like
trip to Europe and I had to have been
traveling for
two months at the time about five weeks
at the time and I was on a ferry boat in
Greece and I was I was reading a book
and I finally felt my brain unwind
it had been five weeks of me just being
in a pressure cooker and and suddenly I
was just like oh
like suddenly the way the final piece
the last straw came off my back right
and you feel it and I don't think people
realize just how wound up and tight they
are all the time with all of the things
that are going on and yet
it's those perceptions that you have to
be able to make to to make these
fundamental shifts in what is that
you're doing and just stay on top of
things so yeah it's exciting and one of
the signature kind of things of of
satisfaction in the behind the scenes
segment of our interview that nobody
ever heard or will hear uh was uh you
know kind of like I asked you you know
Frasier you know where do you like where
would you go with an infinite budget and
you want to uh you want to recapitulate
what you said it was very uh very you
know kind of important for me to hear at
the time
wait a second like if I had an infinite
budget for space and astronomy if you
had a huge budget you know just like 10x
what you have now how would it affect
like me as a oh like me as a as a
journal nothing all right so I probably
I probably said I wouldn't do anything I
I wouldn't even know what to do yeah
okay all right yeah so that to me is
like the hedonic treadmill it's like you
know people you get more subs you want
more subs you get more money you want
more money but it seems to me you're
kind of like that Zen mentality that
like the who's the happy man that's he
he who's happy with what he has and but
I wonder though like if you did kind of
think crazily I mean like podcast
interview on the moon or on the ISS like
what would be like a crazy 10x
experience or 11x experience that maybe
not not like going to the moon or
whatever yet but um what what would like
an interview besides Yours Truly for
like the sixth time uh what's like a
dream kind of either interview or live
stream or uh or like something totally
different like short form content there
what do you do yeah you must um and I
don't I don't I don't I'm like like
there was definitely a time when I'd be
like boy I really wish I could reach out
to Dr Brian Keating he would actually
get back to me and we could do an
interview together but but I can do that
now and and I'm just like I'm shocked at
the people that have had a chance to
talk to you no I mean you too right
Nobel Prize winners
um uh astronomers authors uh astronauts
space scientists
like if this person exists and they have
an email address typically I can
coordinate there might be some nagging
involved but I can typically coordinate
an interview with the person
um
I I definitely feel like the coverage
that we have on Universe today now is is
as good as it
as it
as I want it to be I mean it could
definitely be a little better like I
look at stuff at scientific America like
I see some Outlets which have vastly
bigger budgets than me and I think okay
yeah we could but uh but then I don't
know if it would be sustainable and so
I wonder if they're just burning
investor money like we are sustainable
we are
unkillable in terms of a journalistic
Endeavor and and that feels that feels
that's the balance that makes me the
happiest is I don't want to you know
like if someone dropped 10 million
dollars on my lap I'd be like am I gonna
have to pay this back like how's this
gonna work I don't like I don't wanna I
don't want to think about it like
investors are a bad thing in my opinion
yeah so
um so the more I mean I think like like
the thing is like when I get a chance
like we've had some really amazing
writers join the team some people have
been Legends in the field
um Alan Boyle who is sort of one of my
mentors uh Carolyn Collins Peterson aka
the space writer
um
Nancy Atkins is just about to write her
6 000th article for Universe today and
so like I see a lot of these writers who
I well I love to be able to bring on the
team and I think I've had more budget
that I could bring on even more writers
and more do more stuff so that's all
yeah well that's good to it's good to be
satisfied with where you're at what's
been the most like surprising or
interesting
um Discovery this past year and you
can't use the letters jwst
yeah so so this is an interview that I
just did about a week ago which was a
guy named Dylan brought from the
pantheon plus team and I'm sure you're
familiar with this but Pantheon plus is
this database of
1570 type 1A Supernova seen recently but
also ones that were seen back in 1998
and earlier that helped measure like
help figure out distance in the middle
ranges of the universe and the amount of
precision and effort that they that went
into building this database is really
stunning and the kinds of conclusions
like they were able to measure the
presence of dark matter and dark energy
to 5 Sigma
at various points in the universe
like a one in 3.6 million chance that
they're wrong which is
very low five segment is isn't isn't EX
just an insanely good measurement and so
you've got this beautiful measurement
about the expansion rate of the universe
the amount the dark matter and matter
was pulling at the expansion of the
universe
it's huge it's huge and I think that
that people
people and I'm sure you get this as well
but people will just kind of show up and
go like I don't get dark matter I don't
like it it's you you scientists are
wrong you're just guessing you're like
no no like this has been measured to a
level of precision that we can scarcely
comprehend and yet
there it is
sure nobody knows what it is but that's
like future scientists problem
it's about it's about measuring in
existence its existence with precision
is beautiful and and I just found that
so inspiring I love I mean you know we
talked about this last time on our
interview we're like I am such a fan of
The Observers of the experimenters of
the people who are out there practically
making the measurements
beyond the theorists like I prefer the
experimenters I'll take a I'll take a
party full of experimenters over a party
full of theorists any day of the week uh
an experiment uh theorist only has to be
right once to make a famous career an
experimentalist only has to be wrong
once to end their career although I'm
proof of a counterfactual to that well
sure yeah yeah so uh so I can't help but
read one comment from uh one of the
listeners we're gonna take questions so
I want you all to put your questions in
the uh in the chat box in the live chat
uh and or you can uh you can put them on
YouTube I might get to that uh but
there's a young person that looks like
uh listening from somewhere maybe over
in India perhaps talking about how how
magical it is to be uh to be able to do
this during Diwali which it is Happy
Diwali Frazier that's the festival yeah
of Light which is very important to us
and how it is a billion people are not
watching this broadcast but a billion
people are celebrating this thing United
and that we're communicating at the
speed of light near abouts
um all the way from North America there
I think it is pretty amazing and I feel
like it is a kind of Confluence and and
I I claim it's you know it's a moral
obligation for scientists like me who
get paid by the public
to communicate in terms of the public
can understand you know like I If if I
was working you know in a in an envelope
making factory or whatever and my boss
comes up and says you know Keating what
are you up to oh yeah
can't understand what I'm doing it's
very special yeah she fired fire naked
right so
um what do you believe like when when
people say no you know no I don't want
to come on I mean my fair share of
rejections
um I've I've actually been rejected from
a hundred percent of the living Nobel
Prize winners in physics that are women
um uh but they have good reasons but
like um how do you feel about that when
there is kind of just like burning
knowledge and and I understand why they
did so completely just burn out whatever
um maybe someday I'll keep trying but uh
but I want to ask you you know if you do
encounter kind of the result where there
is some amazing result today I was just
reading about a result from the Ice Cube
neutrino experiment down yes at the
South Pole where I've been twice in my
life and done some research and know a
lot of those guys and gals that work on
that amazing looking at quantum gravity
and I'm like I can't find like who to
like I know people on the project but I
don't know who would be like a good get
so to speak not to boost ratings or
whatever but to communicate as a as a
lay person could understand it but also
knows how do you do that how so I think
you're overthinking it I think you're
totally overthinking it like like I will
see a paper uh there was a paper that I
just read today
about
Stars engulfing their planets
and I was like I want to talk about that
please
um and so then I just look at who's the
first name on the paper and I reached
out to her and I sent her an email and
if she doesn't respond then I'll try the
second person on the paper and then I'll
do the third person and so the person is
not an established science Communicator
they are they're not a household name no
one knows who they are but many times
those people have absolutely fascinating
things to say and they're even better
than a person who does have a lot of
experience because they have have a lot
of canned responses and they've and
they're a little uh nervous and and and
suspicious of talking to a journalist
but a person who it hasn't been burned
yet
um you can have a really interesting
enforcement conversation about the work
that they're doing and it's a joy and so
I don't I have I place zero
uh interest in the
in who the person is
so it's more about I just like I see a
topic that is interesting to me I reach
out to the principal investigator of
that project and I asked if I can do an
interview with them and
I will check beforehand just to see if I
can see some YouTube interviews just to
see if they've ever done anything or
like see them give a presentation at the
American Astronomical Society or
anything
um but I don't
I don't I don't do that math at all and
and they're my favorite conversations by
far like once again you know I'll take a
room I'll take an interview I'll take a
podcast full of no names
than science Stars even though it won't
necessarily bring in the the traffic
right it's gonna be a fascinating
conversation with somebody who has fresh
things to say and you can have a very
natural conversation with them so that
would be you know if I was to give you
some advice yeah it would be you're
overthinking it like yeah just like good
luck like I can claim I discovered a
star you know although she would
probably be correct to dispute me but
Kiara manganelli who's at uh Nelly who's
at UConn stores and Connecticut she's
been a leader in um nanograph and you
know Pulsar timing experiments had some
really interesting results on stochastic
backgrounds gravitational waves and uh
she was on my podcast about three years
ago and then just recently I saw her
pop-up on Sean Carroll's podcast
I'm pretty proud that I got got to her
first yeah I mean sometimes you'll have
these conversations with these people
and they and other people will realize
how well spoken they are and but but
again it's sort of like like if you
could help them move their careers
forward that's wonderful and that's a
really nice side benefit but
it it's more about you finding a name
finding finding a topic like that is
exciting to you and you're curious about
and then finding one name and and then
start talking to that yeah pick one of
those people at random it just yeah I
mean I I actually know I want to lead
professors on the project so I'll
probably have him honor
um yeah Miss Collins but um so when you
think about uh some of the questions
that are coming in from Billy McBride
the Entertainer uh Billy's asking what
is the next Scientific Revolution so if
you had to put your your kind of
predicting hat on maybe not astronomy
maybe anything else but what would you
say is the next Scientific Revolution
and don't say astrology
I'm like oh well okay well there's that
no I mean I think when I think about the
impact that computer science is is
having an artificial intelligence uh you
know we recently got a result that uh
artificial intelligence was able to map
a whole bunch of protein folding
artificial intelligence was able to
figure out a new some new linear algebra
calculation algorithms which is pretty
amazing so it's this Force multiplier
that applies across every field and I
think we're you know in many fields
we're shifting from you can make a
single observation with a really good
tool to meta-analysis of really large
amounts of data you're going to be
studying a million type 1A Supernova
with Vera Rubin to measure the expansion
rate of the universe a human being can't
do that but you can have a computer
assist you as a very powerful tool that
can you can work together to come to the
answer so I so I think the
once we start to apply the computational
power of computers
to the kinds of questions that we have I
think we're going to see another
revolution in across the sciences and
right now most science and I'm sure
decides that you do it's just done as a
very manual process right
right but imagine you could
feed
one billion stars from Gaia data into a
supercomputer or some kind of learning
algorithm and go like you know what
what's in there what's what's
interesting in there and you could pull
some really interesting see some really
interesting
um
patterns
yeah 100 and I wonder you know from the
uh the just wedding of the appetite I
mean I wasn't uh I was a yeah beginning
College I think when Hubble was launched
and you know I wasn't really sure I
wanted to do astronomy uh back then and
uh I wonder you know if you look at Webb
now for the young people that are you
know alive now and have the opportunity
are there things that you know that have
only just begun to scratch the surface
of your cerebral cortex in terms of what
Webb could do or are there things that
you're like I If I Could you know break
their break their wall of silence and
get their embargo lifted just for me and
I'm a journalist as you are uh rather so
what would you want to know what what
kind of what a subject or capability
that we know that Webb probably has is
latent and is most interesting to you to
hopefully find out about soon
yeah I mean I think where I get pretty
like like web is phenomenal it's
gigantic you know 6.5 meters compared to
Hubble's 2.6 meters it can see out just
it can do a Hubble Deep Field in any
direction in like half an hour
it's incredible
but it still has its limit right it
still is only so large I mean it's not
going to be the the telescope that's
going to
find or that's going to be able to look
at the surface of other earth-sized
worlds orbiting around sunlight stars
and tell us what they're eating for
breakfast
but when you match up the power of web
with gravitational lensing
you're adding this additional telescope
lens in front of your of web that gives
you like another 10 000 times resolution
to be able to see objects that are
behind it and then we start to see the
first Stars forming in the universe
um
you know there's some really interesting
periods after the cosmic microwave
background before the period of
realization before the the the first
galaxies were coming together when
a lot of big mysteries about the
universe are hidden and I'm quite
excited about how the way we learn some
amazing things by web users or by Hubble
using gravitational lensing once Webb
starts using gravitational lensing more
dependably I think it's going to be next
level again I think they're under and I
really feel like they're under selling
it like they're not talking about it
right but you take web and you stare at
a gravitational lens that only web can
see
you're seeing something that is
magnified behind it
that is that it would take a a louvar to
be able to see right
right no it's it's so exciting and then
of course you know what the capabilities
are really not known but one thing that
you and I talked about in our most
recent conversation you know
capabilities that maybe web doesn't have
that some people think it does have and
this parlayed into a discussion of you
know the big bang and it's and it's a
possible non-confirmation uh by uh a man
by the name I've heard that I've heard
that the big Bang's been has been
canceled yeah I bunked it I don't know
if that's the proper term but it was
debunked and then I bunked it and then
uh but it's a it's kind of unresolved
what it is you rebunked it you rebunked
the bag the Big Bang got a bunk it you
know yeah not just for beds anymore and
I put a poll up on my on my website uh
my YouTube channel and I asked people in
the community tab you know who won the
debate you know the Big Bang supporters
or the Big Bang never happened supporter
it was about you know two to one maybe
uh there was a little bit of you know
kind of margin of error you know getting
into the election season down here in
America you may know uh and there's
always a margin of error but it wasn't
like you know a hundred to zero uh for
either side which was kind of surprising
to me and I know Eric's learner's
probably listening out there hello Eric
uh but uh but you know the question of
you know can you resolve something
scientifically in the debate format I've
had some debates I I always feel like
debates and Martin Reese who's an
upcoming guest on my show he's he's
basically of the opinion that debates
are pointless I wonder I would agree
with that yeah so uh but what do you
think that scientists have an obligation
to the public in other words there are
all these papers published that Lerner
took and used the title panic at the
discs and blah blah and use that to stir
up kind of this notion that astronomers
are in chaos and there are all these
anomalies we can't explain that's true
there are anomalies we can't explain but
that's the whole point of science
um what uh role should debates have
obviously they have to be done with
committee and a little comedy never
hurts what should the debate be used for
if anything
well I think like like I think that's
what's really important is the way the
scientific method works that that
skepticism and debunking one another is
the is the table Stakes for being a
scientist like your
you're going to be presenting
information and and your
as you again probably are aware of your
colleagues are going to descend on you
like a pack of hyenas to tear apart
every single statement that you make
it makes you stronger it makes you
better it makes you go into your
research very carefully knowing that
you're gonna have to defend every single
scrap of data that you have gathered and
every conclusion that you make
there are no fields that have that level
of rigor and
um
and
sort of combaticism I don't know how you
describe it with each other
like science and yet here we are talking
on the internet using lasers hard drives
I'm using a satellite system to be able
to communicate with you like we are the
beneficiaries of this powerful
philosophy of science and the scientific
method that was really only developed
since the Renaissance I mean it's only
been cranky for a couple hundred years
and yet here we are
and it's and it's only by adhering to
the scientific method that we that we
get there
um and I think that the scientific
method is so powerful and so effective
that it has shaken other philosophies
other beliefs other systems ways of
knowing and it hasn't it's not it's not
like it's been targeted it's just a side
effect
that that the theory of evolution is so
strong and so well defended it has so
many independent lines of evidence that
people will
it will question the the beliefs that
they were raised with and that's not
science's problem science is not coming
after people and saying you know all
that stuff that you were taught it's not
true they're just saying Hey look
these life forms seem to be related to
those life forms this is how life
probably works and and I think that
that that that
process is is so important and I yeah I
mean I just feel like like that is the
what we can sort of all take from it
right and I don't know like like it's
got to affect the way you think right
like the way you interact with your
colleagues is just definitely someone
says something to you like the big bang
isn't real or whatever and your mind
just kind of goes okay so what's your
evidence right yeah it's but there's a I
think it's very valuable you know in
other words there's a there's a concept
in Judaism you know I'm Jewish and
there's a talmudic expression which is
called uh basically it goes uh know how
to answer a heretic which you know kind
of has a lot of loaded terms in it but
but uh but the bottom line is and I
don't think I do a good job I don't
think we as a community of professional
scientists do a great job of just with
like the background foundations you know
I asked Mike uh I have an opportunity
you know once every six years to ask
like any question in physics to a
graduate student on Whose committee I'm
serving right so I love to do like the
general question so I'll ask them you
know uh how do we know that the uh I say
I usually phrase it in the form of
something provocative I'll say I believe
the sun orbits the earth prove me wrong
and they'll be like first of all I'll be
like no no really prove me wrong
um I believe that the you know
5783 years old prove me wrong
um and actually I was in Italy last week
and I was um I had the opportunity to
talk to
uh Professor Luke Barnes who's a
professor in Western Sydney Australia
who is a remarkable person in that he's
a legitimate hardcore theoretical
physicist but he grew up a young Earth
creationist and he and I talked about
you know religion he's Christian I'm
Jewish but we have we had a lot to say
and we were kind of you know at this at
a workshop we're talking about you know
the possible debates between religion
and Science and and he's obviously a
hardcore scient but he and he overcame
though young his father was a was a
minister I can't wait for you to see
this interview he's such an interesting
guy yeah it's an Amazing Creation Church
in Australia uh and yet he went to
Cambridge he ended up working he's an
incredible scientist he overcame the
belief that the universe is Young uh but
I think it's it's very valuable to have
that experience to know like well how do
we know the Big Bang is the most
accurate not infallible not a hundred
percent certainly not is proven and
sometimes as uh one of the one of the
professors who was is there at this
meeting who's not uh not either you know
I think I would call him agnostic as you
know Freeman Dyson was an agnostic an
actual agnostic not just says I'm an
agnostic so that the theists you know
don't try to convert me more or the
atheist you know don't think I'm a Rube
but uh one of the professors there I
won't say who he is because you know
um no
one asked questions even about evolution
Joel absolutely because it's where the
cracks come in that the light gets in
right as as uh what's Leonard Cohen used
to say uh that's how light gets in and I
think in this case I want more of my
students to know to teach the
controversy so it's not that you know
the Earth is flat or something but it
always does kind of devolve into matters
of taste and I think what what I think
both of our audiences like is that we
are we're talking about actually
hardcore The Cutting Edge of technology
and we're not afraid to take on these
controversies even things like you know
our alien visiting us to this day right
yeah well I mean I think that your your
responsibility as a scientist is to do
science and and I think that a lot of
people unfairly are asking more from a
scientist than doing science it's like
asking a mechanic to be a philosopher
like their responsibility is to fix cars
and and all of the work that goes into
the point that they can fix a car and
then they fix cars now they're free to
go beyond that and talk about the
philosophy of fixing cars and and
but I think that there is like an
because whether a car is fixed or not
fixed doesn't crash into somebody else's
worldview
it's a non-controversial job but when
science crashes into someone's worldview
it's not the scientists problem it's not
their fault they are like obviously if
they're rocking if they're proselytizing
if they are going and attending church
and then standing from the middle of the
church and telling everybody that
they're idiots for believing in their
God
that's bad that's wrong but in many
cases the scientist is not doing any of
that the scientist is just like going
like I just I looked at a black hole and
this is what I've and you know here's
what I saw
and now I'm gonna go look at it you know
now I'm gonna go look at the big bang
and here's what I'm gonna see and it's
it's the people with the world view who
are taking offense who are using this as
a chance as a as an existential crisis
for them but that's a them problem not
scientists problem and I think my job as
a science Communicator is to help assist
in
explaining the science that is getting
done in the most honest way that I can
and to take some of that load off the
scientists because they're busy doing
the science it would be literally like
the mechanic having to defend every time
they although you know swipe out an
engine on a car battery like with
respect as I always do you know I was in
as I said I was in Florence I went to
Galileo's you know final home slash
prison which is quite nice and I think
you know Jeffrey Epstein would have
loved to be in a prison like that uh but
um you know when I was there I realized
that you know Galileo not only did he
you know kind of go against the the the
the orders of the church he kind of
disobeyed like on a totally uh you know
kind of propositions from from Pope
Urban I said look you can study it uh
you can study heliocentrism but that
meant doing things in Latin that was you
know I mean Fraser and I of course know
Latin you know we can communicate
flawlessly but but back then that was
the language of of scientists and
Specialists and Italian was the language
of the people and they said it's just as
long as you don't publish anything in
Italian a couple years later the
dialogue which is not uh which is not
Latin That's Italian comes out and then
you know it was so amazing to me to be
in this and it was a prison I mean there
are bars on the Windows there was a
guard out front but it made it so
important to me to see that he was a
communicator Fraser he he wrote another
book you know I've I've published the
first ever audiobook with Jim Gates and
with uh Carlo ravelli Frank wilcheck
Fabiola gianati and others of his
dialogue the dialogue that got him into
trouble but then he published another
book called The discourse and he did
that under house arrest and it was a
prison and uh but somehow Fraser under
penalty of death I mean he was he was
imprisoned under penalty of Suspicion of
heresy not heresy he would have been
killed but it was suspicious edition of
heresy which I guess is a technicality
but if he got this now he actually had
all the pages smuggled as 400 pages long
and it was smuggled to the Netherlands
where it was published by elsevier you
know which publishes a lot of journals
nowadays still like puppets that's
amazing
to communicate to the public and and I
think that's
yeah
yeah I mean the Galilee was picking
fights though like yeah Galileo was
absolutely picking fights he was
absolutely pushing the boundaries I love
him but he's yeah lovable schmuck and he
was the equivalent of standing up in the
middle of the of the church and and
telling everybody that they're wrong and
they're idiots and he was right in this
case about about the observations that
he had he had made
and
and but if he hadn't done that the
discoveries that Galileo had made would
have come out 10 years later by Cassini
or by right like they like they're
inevitable because they're they're
hidden in nature itself and there's only
so long you can go trying to have your
philosophy
overcome nature nature wins out in the
end every single time and and so again
if you are going to set your philosophy
set your belief system against nature
that's a you problem that's nature is
going to show you how you're how wrong
you are every single time yeah
um and so I do think that
you know there are there is bad science
and there is there are bad conclusions
and there are bad actions that get taken
from science but I do think that at the
end of the day it's a scientist's job to
do science and no I I think we place I
think we place too much or people place
too much emphasis on
on
them attempting needing to communicate
what they're doing better but at the
same time I think that you know people
like you people like uh Sabina people
you know people who want to communicate
and and help make this stuff make more
people
is a wonderful Instinct yeah yeah you're
gonna pay a price in that it's going to
take time away from you being able to do
science but the benefit that you get is
you are potentially inspiring more
people out there to do science to
understand what's going on to think
critically to to
you know and there's and and that's
always my kryptonite it's always my
greatest weakness is that I'm not a
cosmologist
can't go right to First principles and
and explain something because I because
I can do the math right and it's really
valuable a lot of authority can come
from a person who can do the math yeah
play or in the South Pole or I have to
talk to you know some some diesel
supplier and it's very little you know
pondering the universe scratching my
non-existent Fraser came like beard but
I do feel like it's uh you know those
are the people I have to talk to uh
including you know telecons of which I
have one in a few minutes anyway but
we're going to go along they're gonna
let them wait for a little bit I've
gotta I've gotta I've got to go with
like half past so whatever you do okay
yeah so I'll see your half pass but I'll
say I gotta go at a quarter past how
about that okay perfect that's the
ultimate Flex uh but but the you know
the bottom line is when I get I get to
talk to people like you I get to talk to
the novel lawyers I get to so it's a
privilege and I do find that that um
only gets better you know as the more I
kind of have cultivated a little bit of
a reputation for kind of just going
after a niche you know which is
cosmology which is science but I I
lately started a branch out I have Neil
Ferguson who's a historian at Stanford
coming on Jay bhattacharya is coming on
he he does a lot of stuff with the kova
19 pandemic
um so I'm not afraid to do that but but
on the other hand
um you know there is also this kind of
Niche thing that that is good to to kind
of dial into
um I wonder now we have a lot of
questions from the audience and then I
have my patented final four questions uh
that I'm gonna demand responses like a
good journalist should yeah yeah I mean
you know like when you talk to those
people that you're going to be you know
they're fairly you know I know who they
are they're controversial yeah
be a scientist yeah
yeah no I mean the the thing for me is
like and at this conference it was very
surprising to me Fraser because you know
I consider myself a you know a
practicing atheist I was practicing
agnostic as a Freudian slip truck but uh
in that I go to like a temple like in
San Diego downtown I go to you know I do
things that keep kosher but like you
know are there evidence do I ever doubt
my faith um and at this conference there
are many many uh scientists professors
very well-known people some of whom will
come on the show at some point and uh
and and you know people like uh Francis
Collins wasn't there but you know he's
like a very religious person obviously
uh but I wonder uh you know I asked them
like do you ever doubt your faith
expecting them to say uh and I asked
that on the atheist too I said Do you
ever doubt your atheism
um you know because like when you see a
baby born like because they're well say
well you see a baby born with a
deformation and cancer like why would
God do that so that's the classic
problem of theodicy right uh but is
there anti-theodicy like you see like a
butterfly come out of a crystal like I
want asked like one of these uh my very
good friends who's extremely pro-choice
and she uh she's just so devoutly
pro-choice and I respect pro-choice up
to a up to a point we can debate that's
not what this podcast is about right but
uh but I was saying like um she told me
like one of her kids bought like a
butterfly kit where you get these little
caterpillars and they're so they're so
cool and then like literally you put
them in they turn to a chrysalis and
then like one day they just start to
hatch and come out and I said yeah I
won't use her name I said to her you
know like
um how would you feel you know you see
this beautiful Chrysalis and he emerges
and it transformed from this like hairy
the squiggly thing like a snake and then
it starts to fly and like what if I came
up to it and I just like crushed it like
right in front of you I would I would
kill you and I was just like but like
can you see where some people on the
other side have and she's like
scientifically binded can you see where
they might have but so I love to ask
them questions is there anything I I
could do to shake your faith in your
position yeah to Jay I'm going to ask
him but Jay about a chair like maybe you
were wrong to publish this study in like
three one three weeks after but the
thing that is so interesting to me
Fraser is that they will have these
talks but someone like you know I can't
imagine Like Richard Dawkins like he
would be in welcome at this conference
but I don't know if he would come and I
don't know if he would invite any of
them to like his conference anyway you
don't have to respond to that because we
have a lot to cover still but um but yes
I will I will I will hold her I mean
that was a journal for me
yeah I mean like for me it's just about
evidence so just like whatever like you
know people ask me about UFOs like do
you believe in UFOs and like I don't I'm
I am unconvinced by the evidence so
um
have and if someone says well my father
saw a UFO I'm like
I don't confine that convincing right
like I'm sure your father found it
convincing and you find it convincing
that your father found it convincing but
that is not enough for me to be
convinced that your father actually saw
an alien spacecraft fly down to earth I
can imagine a bunch of alternative
scenarios and as long as I can how do we
figure out what's true and what's not
true and and and so for all of any time
anyone makes a truth claim to me
I have to figure out a method of
discerning what's true and what's not
true that's right and that is and that
is the same technique about everything
yeah it's just and so I I like I think
it's really dangerous to say
I just I think this thing is wrong
I think it's it's disingenuous I think
it is it's not helpful and and but I
think it's perfectly acceptable to say I
am unconvinced by the evidence you have
presented to me so far
about your UFOs yeah uh yeah but I can't
wait to be proven wrong like please show
me that I'm wrong deliver me the
evidence
and usually it's just silence yeah right
because they don't have any evidence so
it's fine like but but you can't you're
not gonna guilt me you're not gonna
threaten me you're not gonna Cowtown me
into believing something that I don't
have enough evidence for yet but I want
to keep a dramatically open mind able to
tear and what's possible yeah I mean
I've had on I've been on uh Jeremy Reese
who's a alien scientist he's in the chat
room he's he's a good supporter of the
show he's incredibly energetic very
passionate and you know he and I had a
and I give him his do he had me on his
channel you know I'm more on the
slightly on the skeptical scale and he
was genuine about it and generous about
it uh gracious Etc but at the end of the
line I I have a video on my channel that
said astrophysicist Professor I don't
believe in gravity I don't believe in
gravity I have evidence for gravity and
I think yeah that's the thing exactly
yeah Okay so we've got a question from
Andy Oates who's a great friend of my
show he's a subscriber to your channel
as well uh he and another uh member of
the chat room one of your other best
videos in my humble opinions about ion
drives it's one of your most popular
videos we want to talk about space
technology Andy's asking will Artemis
take off in November or will it sit
oxidizing into 2023 so first of all what
excites you about space technology and
the Space Race that's going on today do
you think we're going to reach Mars uh
first answer about artemisari and then
will it take off okay yes I think
Artemis will launch in November I and in
fact I think it'll launch on the first
try so I think November was it 13th 14th
I think it's going to launch like it's
like there's not there's nothing left
right the like unless unless another
hurricane Bears down on Florida then
it's going to launch they've they've
looked through all of their fueling
problems they've they've trouble shot
every single thing that's going to make
them and there's a ton of pressure
they've got go fever for sure and
because there's no human beings on board
I think they're gonna go They're Gonna
err on the side of let's just go so I do
think it's going to launch I think it's
going to beat Starship by far
um I think Starship is like musk said it
might launch in November
um but like you have to multiply musk
time for everything this 33 separate
Raptor 2 engine strapped together in a
configuration that's never been
attempted it feels like there are more
tests that they're going to want to do
before they actually let that monster
get off the off the
the launch pad
I still sort of hold by my completely
unscientific prediction that they're not
going to launch till march-ish okay so
but we'll see if I'm I can't wait again
I can't wait to be wrong like in the
perfect world Starship launches and is
perfect and SLS launches and is perfect
and people have a really difficult time
figuring out what they're going to do
from this point forward but to see two
super heavy lift Rockets take off within
a few days of each other would be the
greatest thing ever
I just do not
must ultimate goal of going tomorrow I
mean do you feel like that is a
legitimate is there scientific
legitimacy even sustenance of human life
on Earth which is his primary Mission uh
what do you make of that ambition that
Moscow yeah I mean I think I can't wait
for there to be a base on the moon I
can't wait for there to be a base on a
asteroid a base on Mars where you've got
human beings living there doing
scientific research search but I don't
think it's ever going to be beyond what
we have in Antarctica
like like they there is a scientific
reason to go to these places if nothing
just to send human beings to other
planets but it is not to try and send
a million people to live on on Mars like
if we could do our very very best
possible job of of making Mars like be
terraformed Mars and we grew plants on
Mars it would still suck compared to
Earth and and after a while that's just
got to get exhausting where you're just
like you know what's a place that's like
a terraformed Mars it's Earth and you
were right there all along that's right
so yeah yeah so I think no I upcoming
guest on the show Lex Friedman uh I I
called him on his show you know I said
you know what happened the day after
life is discovered somewhere in the
universe some slime mold on you know
Vesta and he said what I said absolutely
nothing like 100 you know 10 miles away
and I could scoop up some life and and
you know what you're right yeah
Antarctica I've been there twice has
been a month or more of my life there
you know uh the South Pole you'd have to
pay me to go back to the coast is pretty
bright there's pink yeah
a thousand times more habitable than
Mars like it's a thousand times more
pleasurable than Mars easily okay let's
take some more questions from uh from
the audience
um so feel free to type in your question
underneath uh in the live chat
um you can also uh you know find more
information about Fraser on his channel
I'll put a link to that there I'll put
links to my appearances on um Universe
today with Frasier in the in the past
years
um so uh let's see
um let's see uh was math discovered or
invented that's his earned his bathroom
you believe math is mathematical
um ideas are they discovered or are they
invented by humans
I have no opinion
I mean if it was discovered like
are the math are is one plus one equals
two is that a thing that exists in the
universe or was it invented by human
beings I'm gonna I mean I'm gonna lean
on the side of them being invented
because we do because we do math and
sometimes we do math that doesn't work
but
but I think and you can go back like
isn't there's like you can go right back
and prove that one plus one equals two
so yeah it's about 200 like a long proof
yeah yeah but it's like a foundational
assumption right yeah but I don't really
I don't really have an opinion either
way so yeah I'm gonna have some more
I've had a few mathematicians I've had
Stephen strokeatz I've had Jim Simons
I'm having Ed Frankel who wrote a
wonderful book called love and math he's
coming on the podcast in the near future
stay tuned for that yeah um do you have
an answer for that invention discovered
the answer is yes okay perfect okay good
yeah so my ambivalence is is right okay
yeah because there is sort of a purity
now what's so interesting to me about
this conference and that's why I like to
go to things that I don't necessarily
talk to people I don't necessarily agree
with and that's because you know you
hear things like there was a Eminence if
I told his name I mean he probably
doesn't care if I tell it but he's at
Harvard
um in their molecular biology and math
and does all this incredible and he
basically went through a methodically
this this whole proof that God exist
based on math and I mean it wasn't like
really crazy crackpot I mean Einstein
said things Galway Galileo Hometown
whose Hometown we're in God is a
mathematician of the very highest order
uh Eugene wigner you know what is the
essence to explain the to human beings
the unreasonable effectiveness of math
to physics it's a it's a puzzle it's a
mystery anyway I want to get more into
technology now uh Andy Oates asked
what's your opinion about Thorium rocket
engines or can you give us an update on
your ion drive what do you what excites
you about space like besides these
ginormous Rockets what other
Technologies are needed to enable us to
go to planets or the soul of stars
beyond our solar system
well that I mean ion drives this is this
idea of of having ionized particles
using the Xenon Krypton and you blast it
on the back of your of your rocket using
an electric field and you get very high
accelerations in return but it's
on a particle by particle levels the
actual Force coming out of an ion engine
is is very low but the efficiency is
very high and and when you're
considering the tyranny of the rocket
equation efficiency is is the most
important thing so you can accelerate to
really high velocities over long periods
of time by firing your Ion engine
um there's a new type of ion engine
that's being developed by NASA that's
going to see
existence in future missions so there's
some more powerful ones out there and
when you
connect a fusion reactor to ion engines
you get a pretty great technology stack
you've got really high efficiency
Limitless amount of Power with ion
engines capable of using that power to
accelerate your propellant out I think
if there's going to be missions going to
and from Mars we're going to see ion
engines play a role in that but but I
think that the revolution in rocketry
right now is what's happening with
SpaceX with Starship the idea of a fully
reusable two-stage rocket system like
like if you didn't have to throw your
rocket away every single time that you
could just
um
use the
the
like just the cost of the fuel each time
to launch a rocket you could bring down
the cost of launching things by an order
or two of you know several orders of
magnitude which makes a lot of missions
which seemed impossible
in the past suddenly start to make sense
right which brings launching propellant
Depots things like that so I think it's
it's not going to be complicated it's
going to be really simple like it's
but it is rocket science building the
fully reusable two-stage rocket is going
to be the is what's going to be exciting
which brings us you know full circle to
what got you into uh space which was the
shuttle missions which were pioneered to
bring us to space on a weekly basis or
whatever never really care about
um yeah exactly the reasons we're not
going to get into one thing we need to
have and that people are curious about
in the chat room is um you know the
human being going tomorrow so Martin
Reese when he was on the podcast
recently uh said you know Elon Musk
wants to die on Mars and um and and Ela
and then he said to Elon Elon I hope
it's not on impact but there are these
you know kind of
um there and I also asked him like how's
it feel to be the astronomer Royal to
the king now because he used to joke
that his job was to tell the queen her
horoscope uh so you'll hear some of that
in a couple of weeks when I process the
episode but anyway oh that's that's
amazing we might have to like put people
in suspended animation like uh what was
that movie a couple years ago so I
wonder you know can you answer you know
kind of the human question before we
turn to final questions and then wrap up
how are we going to actually physically
get a human being two years or perhaps
longer maybe much much longer to go to
another star system how is that possible
well I mean like like within the solar
system flights of two years you're
taking a human being that was evolved
under the protective magnetosphere of
planet Earth and and our atmosphere and
you're putting them out into the cosmic
void they're going to be getting hit by
cosmic rays they're going to be getting
hit by by radiation from the Sun and
they're going to receive a lifetime's
dose of radiation in just a few months
the price they will pay is cancer
and cardiovascular disease and problems
with their eyes like they in the same
way that a test pilot takes on the risk
of of dying every time they strap into
some new vehicle uh they do it as a as a
as one of the risks of their job
um it's sort of like the same thing
about a person who's going to climb
Mount Everest like you said you know
that there's a 15 chance you're just
gonna die
when you climb that mountain and and
that's just and it's outside of your
control so
there is no solution and like maybe
there'll be some long term like in 200
years from now we'll have technological
solutions to solve all these problems
but but until then we are it is not a
tourist trip to Mars it is a
potentially suicide mission for a lot of
people and almost certain health issues
for everybody who attempts this journey
and think for a lot of people it's worth
it like they're stoked to go to Mars and
they're willing to pay the price
which is that they're going to die young
with cancer and that's the sacrifice
that they're willing to make to extend
Humanity's influence to other places I
wouldn't
but they do and I respect them for what
they're willing to do
um and I don't think there's anything
more like I and I think that people just
don't appreciate
how dangerous it is how unforgiving that
planet is how awful the journey is going
to be and how little reward we're going
to have for actually being there yeah
okay Fraser we've reached the end of our
regularly scheduled content but I do
always love to ask my guests who honor
me by coming on
with uh with these four questions of
fundamental existential reality okay so
the first one is uh relates to the
namesake of the Arthur C Clarke Center
for human imagination that I am the uh
associate director of I have the honor
of being the associate director of and
uh and it has to do with his famous
statement in the very uh in the very
movie 2001 uh Space Odyssey which gave
us a name podcast I don't know if you
know that the podcast comes from the
iPod which came from the word pod bay
doors which I open every podcast with uh
and that's uh what Dave says to how
right okay anyway getting around that uh
so any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable for magic
um I want to ask you what thing have you
discovered in your peregrinations Around
The World of Science and Space that is
most impressive that is most magical
that is most technological perhaps um
that you would like to have the humanity
have a little bit of a Swagger in our
Collective steps about what is the most
impressive most magical advanced
technology
well I think the like
you know I see so many of these things
and they sort of fall out of my brain as
soon as I see them but the thing that
I've been mulling around with right now
is artificial intelligence
content
creation generation the how you've got
things that are writing words drawing
pictures uh
it's really unsettling to
type in a text description of some scene
and have a picture show up in front of
you instantaneously and that really
feels like it's bordering on Magic to me
and I understand the underlying
technology to some degree
uh
it's so weird and and yet it felt like
if you said like when will you be able
to say
computer show me a picture of an
astronaut riding a horse
when will that technology exist a
computer will just show you pictures of
astronauts riding the horses
I would have thought it would have been
50 years from now and yet here we are
right and so to see Things Fall
technologically
so quickly
it's just it's stunning to think about
the future that we're rushing headlong
into
across all these fields of artificial
intelligence yeah I mean I think back to
my grandmother you know grew up in the
state Hall of Eastern Poland and you
know she was riding a horse and putting
a donkey cart and she lived you know to
see men grown men
twerking on Tick Tock and to have that
Frasier is is just so okay next I would
have endowed him in my second thing yeah
oh you know you'll love it that's great
okay the next thing
uh that I love to ask my guests who
honor me um actually it has to do with
um not millions of years in the future
but but maybe uh 70 80 years in the
future when you reach the biblical age
of 120 years old what wisdom not
Material Goods what wisdom do you want
to put in what's called your ethical
will in other words a gathering of of
knowledge but but really of wisdom that
you can communicate to not just your
biological relatives but your
ideological relatives what would you
like to leave for Humanity to guide us
in the future when you're no longer with
us physically
well I think
you know the one of the things that got
me into space and astronomy in the first
place was this this idea that we may or
may not be alone in the universe and
that finding out an answer to that
question is one of the most important
I guess like the most scientific
important question we can ask
and
and I would love to know that I helped
get an answer to it if possible and not
you know I mean obviously I'm not a
scientist so my job is to communicate my
job is to connect my job is to is to
help raise awareness that this is a
scientific question and that the answers
the search for the answers are
fascinating and important and I think
if people can go back and say oh Fraser
helped communicate when we thought it
was stupid Fraser helped us realize that
it was important I would feel like it's
a life well lived that's wonderful okay
last two questions
um now I want to ask you uh also
pertinentus or Arthur C Clarke who said
the following when a distinguished but
elderly scientist says that something is
possible
they are almost certainly right
but when he says something is impossible
they are very probably wrong now I'm not
calling you elderly or about the same
age but I want to ask you Fraser is
there something you've changed your mind
on what have you most recently changed
your mind on that maybe you're wrong
about in the past
well I think the the thing that I've
changed from people from my audience
will know
we've talked a bit about that the the
reason
the worthwhileness of of sending humans
to Mars of of us living here I read the
case where I mentioned earlier the case
for Mars inspired me to get into this
field and the idea of us colonizing Mars
was really exciting to me and I think
that now I
that is no longer interesting to me that
that the more I learn about our planet
the more I appreciate the more I learn
about the universe the more I appreciate
the world that we happen to be on how is
it isn't it weird that we are perfectly
evolved to live on this on this planet
so this is the best place in the
universe yeah and I'll take any aliens
on if they if they disagree with me that
their planet is is better but it's the
best place for us and so it's like you
could search your whole life
for a better place and it turns out you
were living there all along yeah
and don't squander it and I think that
takes us to our final question Fraser
now we're going to go backwards in time
no more going forward time traveling uh
Sir Arthur C Clarke's so-called third
law states the only way of discovering
the limits of the possible is to venture
a little way past them into the
impossible now you know where I get the
name of the podcast from I want to ask
you what mysterious aspect of life as I
said most of my audience is you know 20
to 56 year old men
um I want to give you uh get your life
advice to your former self what would
you do differently what moments of great
clarity or some inciting incident or
something that was formative to you
would you go back to if you like and
give yourself advice to give yourself
the confidence to do as you've done and
go into the impossible advice to your
former self
yeah I mean I think I've been really
fortunate that
I've always been
who I am like as a
when I was in high school I was running
role-playing games I was
um you know I was the d d nerd I was
I was enthusiastic and would never stop
talking and and that shifted into
various interesting careers and stuff
and so I was never ashamed
to be into the things that I that I was
and I think that if I could go back and
and talk to younger Fraser
I'd be like just double down lean in
it's these things that you love video
games space
are fine and are
you're not alone and
and just
do it and I think that that for me
you know be back then you're more
classified as a geek as a nerd as a as
someone who you know wasn't cool and I
it never really bothered me too much but
I think for a lot of people
they they do
they can't be their authentic self and I
think if the the sooner you can get into
embracing your authentic self the more
fun you're gonna have with life for sure
absolutely
razor I want to be uh completely honest
you are a true hero to many of us that
are trying to do a very difficult thing
which is to increase science literacy I
think the future of the earth depends on
it uh we're always oh how do we get more
people in stem well one way is to make
it accessible make it fun and bring
humor uh because humor allows a sense of
confidence that I think you really have
this unique as I said your unfair
Advantage uh which you exploit in the
most benevolent of ways is such a gift
and I want to encourage my you know my
audience uh to definitely subscribe if
you haven't support him on patreon this
is a very important Mission he employs
many many writers and they have this
Mission and so unified
um and one of my favorites uh I keep
promising to have her on Nancy Atkinson
uh who wrote 11 years to the Moon I
think and uh yeah have her on you have
this incredible staff it costs money to
keep that going so please do support
Fraser subscribe to his channel and the
best thing of all is the the you will
reap the benefit benefits of interacting
with Fraser the more you give the more
you'll get Fraser thank you so much
enjoy the rest of your day sorry I kept
you so long but it was too much fun no
problem yeah the timing is good I got
three minutes
take care all right